Katrina: 没有你在
Katrina: Without you here
Jake: 硕
Jake: Shure
Shure: 哎哎哎
Shure: Hey hey hey
Shure: OK
Jake: OK OK
Katrina:  你那个甜品展架啥的买了吗
Katrina: Did you buy that dessert stand?
Tasha: 买了
Tasha: I bought it
Katrina: OK
Jake: 啊这个可以
Jake: Ah, this is good
Tasha: 哎他这个居然没有停止他的进度哎
Tasha: Wow, he didn't even stop his progress
Jake: 呃我们先收拾收拾去吧
Jake: Uh, let's clean up first
Shure: 一想到刚刚所有人都在外面
Shure: Just thinking about everyone being outside
Shure: 然后在里面洗澡
Shure: And then taking a bath inside
Shure: 好好羞耻
Shure: So embarrassing
Katrina:  害怕不
Katrina: Are you scared?
Katrina:  害怕我们进去吗
Katrina: Scared we might go in?
Tasha: 还好你没洗碗
Tasha: Good thing you didn't wash the dishes
Jake: 那那你你先画我们先上去
Jake: Then, you draw first, we'll go upstairs
Katrina: 我马上就来
Katrina: I'll be there soon
Shure:  你画什么
Shure: What are you drawing?
Katrina: 线条小狗
Katrina: A sketch of a puppy
Tasha: 你要在楼上洗碗吗
Tasha: Are you going to wash dishes upstairs?
Katrina: 这是线条小狗吧
Katrina: This is a sketch of a puppy, right?
Jake:啊
Jake: Ah
Tasha: 是在楼上洗碗吗
Tasha: Are you washing the dishes upstairs?
Jake: 是啊
Jake: Yes
Shure:  我们要洗碗
Shure: We need to wash the dishes
Shure:  是吧
Shure: Right?
Jake: 洗了吗
Jake: Washed them?
Shure: 没洗呢
Shure: Not yet
Nicous: 你把那个洗洁精带上去
Nicous: Take the dish soap upstairs
Tasha: 带这个厨房湿巾就行了
Tasha: Just bring these kitchen wipes
Alice:上面有洗衣液吗
Alice: Is there laundry detergent upstairs?
Nicous: 右边右边
Nicous: To the right, to the right
Alice:不是不是洗衣液洗洁精
Alice: No, no, dish soap
Nicous: 对呀带上去
Nicous: Yes, bring it up
Shure: 我的酒快要喝完了
Shure: My drink is almost finished
Katrina:  我的酒还剩一口
Katrina: I have one sip left of my drink
Shure: 这么点
Shure: That little
Shure:  你的这种这种行为咦
Shure: Your behavior, ugh
Katrina: 这行为咋啦
Katrina: What's up with this behavior?
Shure:  就剩个斧根就把斧根留给别人了
Shure: Just leaving the axe handle for someone else.
Katrina: 呵呵我是这样的
Katrina: Haha, I'm like that.
Katrina: 我所有东西都只剩一口
Katrina: I always leave just one bite of everything.
Katrina: 哎呀
Katrina: Oh dear.
Katrina: 不符合世界环保日和世界地球日
Katrina: It doesn't align with World Environment Day and Earth Day.
Katrina: 哎呀这画跟坨屎一样
Katrina: Oh man, this painting looks like a pile of crap.
Katrina:  这样
Katrina: Like this.
Shure: 041756怎么写一遍0417
Shure: How do you write 041756 again, 0417?
Shure:  现在是2058
Shure: Now it's 2058.
Shure:  又被套进去了
Shure: Got trapped again.
Katrina:  这简笔画真做的越来越好看了
Katrina: These doodles are getting prettier and prettier.
Katrina:  好恶心的舌头
Katrina: Such a disgusting tongue.
Katrina:  画的跟爷爷一样
Katrina: Drawn just like grandpa.
Nicous: 我靠我发现没有你我卖不了一点
Nicous: Wow, I realize without you, I can't sell anything.
Nicous: 基本根本找不到
Nicous: I basically can't find anything.
Katrina: 来吧我正好想买东西
Katrina: Come on, I just want to buy stuff.
Katrina: 又不用花自己的钱
Katrina: Without spending my own money.
Nicous: 买什么什么
Nicous: What do you want to buy?
Katrina: 化妆品
Katrina: Makeup.
Shure: 什么化妆品
Shure: What makeup?
Katrina: 你会吗你给你女朋友挑过吗
Katrina: Do you even know? Have you ever picked for your girlfriend?
Shure: 没有
Shure: No.
Katrina: 你这
Katrina: You see?
Nicous: 他没有女朋友他只有好兄弟
Nicous: He doesn't have a girlfriend, he only has good buddies.
Katrina: 他生气喽
Katrina: He's mad.
Nicous: 他不会生气的
Nicous: He won't get mad.
Nicous: 这是他的骄傲
Nicous: It's his pride.
Katrina: soulmate人家是soulmate
Katrina: Soulmates, they are soulmates.
Shure: 兄弟你好香
Shure: Bro, you smell nice.
Shure: 嘿嘿嘿啊
Shure: Hehe, yeah.
Shure: 好兄弟就应该躺在一张床上
Shure: Good bros should sleep on the same bed.
Katrina: 可以听吗
Katrina: Can I listen?
Shure: 可以听
Shure: Sure, you can listen.
Shure: 你不止可以听你可以加入
Shure: Not only can you listen, you can join in.
Nicous: 你真喝多了
Nicous: You're really drunk.
Katrina: 可是被录下来了呀
Katrina: But it's being recorded.
Nicous: 录下来发给我我直接给他对象
Nicous: Record it and send it to me, I'll send it straight to his partner.
Shure: 什么乐死你了啊
Shure: What's so funny about that?
Katrina: 怎么这样
Katrina: How could you do that?
Shure: 就是不说好
Shure: Just don't talk about it.
Shure: 我在这七天里
Shure: In these seven days,
Shure: 闭口不谈吗
Shure: I won't mention it, right?
Nicous: 不谈
Nicous: Don't mention it.